what's it like to have your life story
told on the big screen
so when you say I say a lot of things
I'm a politician for what you did so
that low-income students could go to
private schools well I want to do that
here you have a better chance of winning
the lottery than getting that done the
new movie Miss Virginia tells the
unlikely story of Virginia Walden Ford
who as a single mother in Washington DC
in the early 2000s fought to create a
federally funded private school voucher
program that would allow poor kids
including her son to escape failing
public schools against long odds and
institutional hostility she succeeded
and has played with fiery passion by
orange as the new blacks lose o aduba
every time she says my name is Jeffrey
junior Walden I freaked out I just go oh
my gosh she's using my name that kind of
silliness so I'm is surreal I never ever
thought that anybody would even notice
our fight so it also is something you
know I mean we were a ragtag group of
parents going up on the hill talking to
members of Congress to help save our
kids and so it's it's surreal and unreal
to me what in your experience with the
DC Public Schools and your son what what
was the essential thing that they were
failing him by I think he was just one
of those kids who's just gonna fall
through the cracks
you know if somebody didn't intervene I
remember going to school one day to talk
to a teacher about a class that he had
said he was having trouble with and she
didn't even know who he was
she had 40 kids in her class Walden
Ford's own backstory as a student as
both harrowing and inspirational she was
among the early waves of black kids that
integrated public schools in Little Rock
Arkansas in the late 1950s an experience
that informed her actions as a parent I
remember my dad saying you going to
central Oahu no I'm not okay I'm going
to the black high school and he told me
you have a responsibility to go to
central and do well because you have
younger siblings and the world will look
at you based on the fact that you let
you know paved the way for your younger
siblings
even 14 I was 14 I took that really
seriously and I really believe my
parents were people that serve the
community and I see I remember thinking
that's someone I want to make a
difference so I 14 I knew that I was
gonna do things that would make a
difference that I was gonna serve my
community but it was based on my parents
my grandfather was a slave who bought
his brothers out of slavery and ran a a
bakery in Little Rock that's how he
raised the money and in knowing that I
had that kind of legacy and my family
certainly impacted Who I am and who my
sisters and but service was a big deal
when Daddy got the job at the Ross
School District he was the first black
assistant superintendent for Laurette
School District you know the Klan burned
Krause in our yard it rocks to our
windows and I remember dad my dad saying
you know don't be mad change the world
there's a bit of irony in that as a
child as a young person you fought for
for access to the public schools as a
parent you were fighting for the right
of exit from the public school system
what is the what's the consistent
through line in those actions in both
actions were fighting for quality
education during some rights movement
when we were trying to get into public
schools it was not to get in the
building it was to get what was in the
building you know we were taught with
books there were oftentimes out-of-date
science labs where 20 kids from use one
microscope or or those kinds of things
that really keep kids from getting what
they really everybody ignored was a was
a lie I mean it was separate yes when
schools started changing and they
deteriorate and I remember saying this
is not acceptable
actually I seen speeches all the time to
African Americans I know why you mad
about it coming out of public schools
and stuff I know how you felt I was
there and
but do you really want I can't sustain
bad schools you know because we [ __ ]
60 years ago to get in another building
that's not what we want so you gotta get
it in your head this is something
different I remember telling Ted Kennedy
one time you know your brothers [ __ ]
you know for us to get into traditional
public schools and why are you fighting
against us getting out of these same
schools because they're bad they said we
would fail
they say that we don't care about our
kids one of the most persistent and
paternalistic criticisms of parental
empowerment in education is that poor
and educated parents simply don't have
the background or the intelligence to
make informed decisions for their kids
Walden Ford is having none of that every
time we went to a meeting in the
communities that we were serving which
were low income communities in
Washington and I would ask Q&A you know
we'd do a Q&A and I would say what do
you want for your child low-income
parents will come there with lists of
what they wanted for their children and
they were articulate and passionate and
it was amazing to hear them speak about
what they would what their desires were
and what they would hope for their
children if their children an
opportunity to go had an opportunity to
go to a school that served them well
what's the basic metric of a successful
school in a in a choice environment for
you when you walk into a school and kiss
a smile and they're engaged and they're
safe and parents are involved that's a
key to a successful school and they have
the quipment and library so that kind of
stuff is more important than test scores
or you know I think you do have to test
kit I mean I think you'd have to
determine where they are and what they
need to learn but I think they you can't
define their whole existence
test scores I think there are a lot of
things that go along with there with the
DC Opportunity Scholarship Program in
their initial years the fact that kids
were safe and the parents were happy and
they were graduating at 20% above the
rate of DC Public Schools that was way
more important than test scores that
were going to you know people never did
understand if when I kids went into
those schools they were behind so they
had to catch up and so test scores in
the early years for some time just not
correct you know and the same kids were
waiting graduated he graduated
valedictorian but in DC public school he
his test scores were three or four
levels below wherever whatever grade he
was in and I just had to fight him to go
to school I dropped him off school he'd
leave he'd you know I would drive away
and he'd just be gone I get a call for
schools and he wasn't there
but when he was moved to a private
school he liked it he liked going there
he would jump up and get ready for
school and I asked him why are you
acting like that okay I'm waiting for
the other shoe to drop were you gonna do
something silly you know and he'd say
mama and thirteen years don't talk like
this but he said mom for the first time
in my life I believe others care about
me learning other than you Walden Ford
is adamant that partisan politics not
get in the way of helping children she
acknowledges that having Donald Trump
support school choice is a good thing
for the movement even as it possibly
makes reform harder to sell among blacks
and Latinos she's equally dismayed that
none of the leading Democratic
candidates for president has embraced
school choice she's especially troubled
by senator Cory Booker who as mayor of
Newark New Jersey was a strong proponent
of education reform
I am constantly disappointed every time
I read some especially from Corey
because I know him well and I know what
a big supporter he was what's so easy to
say and I'm a Democrat so easy for us to
say they just need more money I mean
that is that's
the most wrongheaded way of thinking
about education these days it's not just
about more money it's about a result
it's about achievement it's about how
we're delivering that education and the
choices were giving our parents to me
it's disappointing and and that's why I
think this is the best time ever for
this film to come out because what I'm
seeing is a lot of people that are
supporting people that oppose school
choice to get elect and that really
concerns me if we don't figure out how
to get everybody on the same page about
educating children this country is going
to be a mess anyway now poor kids have
just as much of a right to learn as rich
ones
however the 2020 election plays out or
even how the school choice movement
involves Walden Ford is emphatic that
Miss Virginia the movie version of her
life has a message that needs to be
clearly understood and embraced you know
you have every right to look at your
child and determine where he will best
be taught and that's what I want parents
to take away you don't have to sit back
and just take it at the end of the day
this movie certainly is my story but
it's any parent's story it's every
parent's story who ever fought for their
children so it honors the parents
[Music]